set up yours
got everyone it's your boy bang Chan
you're not a boy okay you're an adult
someone in the studio oh see me in the
studio yeah
hello Felix yes hello
hi I'm Han hashtag love puppies
and uh we are going to be doing an
interview with BuzzFeed
[Applause]
when you're on the moon
oh my God my lovely puppies
yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah
[Music]
we're performing on the tables wow
[Music]
um I think we guys love to perform God's
menu
[Music]
it's the language
hey what's your name
pipes and screws
[Music]
come here
[Music]
well he's in a slump right now why are
we puppies
play with puppies and members and ah
don't fight hang out with friends or
watch your movies
healthy
[Music]
stretching stretching stretching yeah
so like before we go on stage say like
oh you know let's do well today
let's stay strong yes
[Music]
foreign
music video
[Music]
this is our own personal coffee machine
and we're using it all together besides
me yay that's why the control was so
difficult to control
until now I'm not using it
poppies yeah yes like cute guys
[Music]
thank you
and this really have
yeah yeah
slip down drink me eat more yeah drink
milk please what's wrong with you
yeah go to Jeffy and join the audition
when you're in 17 years old yeah oh and
you guys start swimming okay okay
your back muscles okay please
why are piggy banks so why because
they're filled with common sense
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Monday chest it was a pack
Monday is chess Tuesday is back
Wednesday is shorter is
[Music]
I already did a collaboration with dial
and somebody and that song is called no
problem later on I guess for fun I will
probably say pizza sometimes it's so
cute up here
[Music]
art was my friend
it feels like being happy happy oh he's
so happy yeah it makes me happy so my
favorite
um art collection are my flowers with
oil uh
I love oceans
yeah oh my God
shoot
you guys most watched that key drama the
whole tool here it's really fun and I
made a song about that
yesterday yesterday yeah oh and I will
show you one day thank you
[Music]
my future plan is to beat Han and
Champion Joe rapping
I have a big plan so please look for it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
one day I just want to travel the this
whole world
maybe with you really yeah chubby sad I
want to make my own Cafe
man
let me tell you about you guys too okay
yeah lovely
you want to produce his own song
like you little munchkins come here come
here
[Music]
you're doing a good job yeah grow up
yeah me too
and so it's emotional
I like the song that Han wrote um
[Music]
thank you
2 A.M
it should be like in the morning
taking a shower a lot of stuff comes out
let me take a shower I think it's
because like you're really relaxed so
maybe that might be why it's so playful
wow
[Music]
wow that's a good question
um
maybe
oh I hope so I mean we don't have any
plans yet but um maybe we could yeah we
can release oh wow too oh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yes of course the recent one that we
I guess shared by ourselves it was the
one we were so synchronized oh we did
the same action like yeah same action
yeah that was crazy
[Music]
[Music]
mama is really big and huge oh really
don't like other puppies yes Barry
thinks that she's a person we take their
dog Papa but then she'd get really
scared so she'd like only stay with us
she doesn't like other dogs I think
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's really free looking at them and
then kind of like them resembling us I
think that was kind of memorable I think
because they're so chaotic but then if
you look at us we're really chaotic too
well Unstoppable thank you BuzzFeed
so all these puppies are adoptable at
North Shore Animal League America yeah
and please show them a lot of love
please look forward to what we're coming
up with next all right so see you next
time
[Music]
foreign